den kolonialismus meine damen und herren
haben die im geschichtsunterricht alle
durchgenommen
eine vergangene epoche möchte man meinen
in der sich westliche mächte anmaßen
andere länder zu besetzen und deren
bevölkerung zu unterdrücken
doch mein heutiger gast pankatz mishra
sagt der kolonialismus ist mitnichten
vorbei sondern dem westlichen denkens
nach wie vor tief eingeschrieben in form
einer ungehörigen arroganz diese
arroganz könnte den westen umso teurer
zu stehen kommen aus der besten selbst
ein auslaufmodell darstellt diese
diagnose will ich heute besser verstehen
und mit meinem gas diskutieren wie eine
echte verständigung zwischen orient und
okzident aussehen könnte ich freue mich
sehr dass pan kosmischer unsere
einladung angenommen habt er ist ein
vielfach ausgezeichnete schriftsteller
und schreibt essays für renommierte
zeitungen wie die new york times oder
der guardian oder ist in london ebenso
zu hause wie in einem kleinen dorf im
himalaya herzlich willkommen herr
michael micha sie haben 2012 dieses buch
geschrieben aus den ruinen des empire
stil wollte gegen den westen und der
wieder aufstieg asiens und dieses buch
ist vielfach preisgekrönt worden sie
würden damit auch bei uns berühmt sie
erzählen die kolonialgeschichte
eigentlich aus der sicht des ostens und
sie sagen in diesem buch aber auch die
kolonialgeschichte ist nicht vorbei
woran machen sie das fest
sie ist nicht vorbei weil menschen in
weiten teilen asiens immer noch auf
diese geschichte reagieren
in westeuropa wurde sie weitgehend
vergessen von den nachfahren diejenigen
die einst große teile asiens beherrscht
haben in asien aber gibt es menschen die
immer noch auf diese geschichte zurück
kommen und sie auf erstaunlich radikale
art aufnehmen so dass sie in diesem teil
der welt sehr lebendig ist
sie können das daran erkennen wie zum
beispiel die chinesen auf die usa oder
auch das heutige europa reagieren
ein beispiel geben die art wie sie
ständig an das jahrhundert der
demütigungen erinnern nun um was geht es
beim jahrhundert der demütigungen
das sind 100 jahre während der westliche
mächte china gezwungen haben das zu tun
was sie von china wollten ihnen
stützpunkte flotten basen zur verfügung
zu stellen oder die zoll politik nach
westlichen bedürfnissen auszurichten
die preisgabe von souveränität all die
demütigungen die westliche mächte china
auferlegten dieser erinnerung ist immer
noch lebendig und bildet heute die basis
des chinesischen nationalismus
vielleicht lohnt es sich mal kurz eine
karte anzusehen ich habe eine
mitgebracht von 1914
da sieht man einfach einmal die den den
ausmaß der kolonialisierung man ich
glaube man kann sich die karte gar nicht
genügend oft ansehen beispielsweise in
rosa das britische empire riesen
riesengroßen leben zum beispiel auch in
indien natürlich alles zugedeckt von
dieser farbe jetzt haben sie vorhin
gesagt ein grund dafür dass der
kommunismus nicht vorbei ist es
sozusagen dieses recent dieses immer
noch übelnehmen dieser geschichte ist
denn dieses nicht vorbeigehen eigentlich
fahren diese historische last
absolut angefangen hat es im späten
neunzehnten jahrhundert als fast jedes
europäische land ein eigenes weltreich
wollte die briten waren die ersten
gefolgt von den franzosen
dann nach der reichsgründung wollen auch
die deutschen ein eigenes imperium sogar
italien wollte ein eigenes reich sie
wollten zum beispiel eine basis in china
ein merkwürdiges phänomen menschen
schwärmen aus herrschen über menschen in
asien dominieren deren wirtschaft
besetzen ihre gebiete und befehlen und
man müsse die dinge nun auf unsere art
und so wie wir es euch sagen wir wissen
dass der konkurrierende imperialismus
zwischen den europäern schließlich zu
zwei großen weltkriegen geführt hat
diese gier der leute die deutschen
wollten ein eigenes welt es stellte sich
heraus dass zum zeitpunkt als sie ins
spiel kamen dieses so gut wie vorbei war
also wollten sie innerhalb von europa
ein reich errichten was zum zweiten
weltkrieg führte wie wir wissen
diese geschichte ich weiß nicht weshalb
leute denken diese geschichte sei vorbei
sie begleitet uns nach wie vor
diese geschichte hat die moderne welt
geprägt der imperialismus ist die basis
der modernen welt spezifischer
ausgedrückt es geht um eine form
wirtschaftlichen wachstums das immer
noch auf expansion angewiesen ist auf
die ausweitung von märkten die
ausdehnung der produktion
dafür muss man in die welt hinaus man
muss ständig in die welt hinaus und neue
territorien finden rohstoffe märkte das
steht in engem zusammenhang mit der
ideologie der modernen welt die auf
expansion basiert diese geschichte ist
nicht vorbei im moment erleben wir
vielmehr die in höhepunkt dieser
geschichte das widerspiegelt sich in den
verschiedensten dingen das ist genau der
punkt oder dass sie sagen es geht nicht
nur darum dass diese geschichte passiert
ist da kann man sich dafür entschuldigen
möglicherweise mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit haben das hin zu
wenig getan
aber selbst wenn man das getan hätte ist
es nach wie vor so dass es irgendwie
eine form von neo kolonialisierung gibt
eine möglichkeit dass zum ausdruck zu
bringen nicht derjenige dass immer
wieder leute darauf hinweisen im grunde
genommen ist der westen geprägt von
einer doppelmoral
man spricht immer von diesen
menschenrechten aber wenn es darum geht
in der globalen wirtschaft
menschenrechte zu berücksichtigen wir zu
wenig getan ist das eine ein argument
dass sie auch vertreten werden sogar bis
auf jährlich gesagt bin ich diesem
argument gegenüber etwas misstrauisch
weil ich der meinung sind es ist
offensichtlich dass westliche
europäischer imperialismus in
verschiedenen teilen der welt viel
schaden angerichtet hat aber wenn wir
uns auf das geschäft von
entschuldigungen und wiedergutmachungen
einlassen laufen wir gefahr zu heuchlern
zu werden
das erklären imperialismus ist kein
spezifisch westliches produkt menschen
in verschiedenen teilen der welt haben
das praktiziert moderner imperialismus
hingegen der mit kapitalismus verbunden
ist unterscheidet sich stark von dem was
wir zuvor bei den römern unter den
osmanen gekannt haben aber dieser
moderne imperialismus wird heute auch
von ländern wie china oder indien
praktiziert vielleicht haben sie keine
ausländischen territorien die sie
unterwerfen oder ausbeuten aber wenn sie
sehen wie sie ihre minderheiten
behandeln die regionen in welchen
minderheiten leben ist das eine sehr
kolonialistische beziehung denn leute in
diesen ländern sagen die briten müssten
historische verletzungen anerkennen und
man müsse eine art gerechtigkeit
etablieren sei es durch einen reparation
system oder etwas anderes dann muss man
diese leute fragen was ist mit den
tibetern was ist mit dem kaschmir ihs
wie lasst ihr dort gerechtigkeit walten
ich glaube man läuft gefahr gegenüber
all diesen anderen ungerechtigkeiten
blind zu werden die in einigen dieser
länder geschehen
die nun für sich in anspruch nehmen die
opfer des in der real is muss zurück
präsentieren
während sie in vielen fällen selber
imperialisten sind was mir sehr klar
wurde dass ich ein buch gelesen habe ist
das ja eigentlich auch so etwas sagen
wie wirkliche verständigung funktioniert
nur wenn wir versuchen zu verstehen was
die jeweiligen teile in der welt
eigentlich aus welt historisch
bedeutende ereignisse wahrnehmen und
interessant ist ja dass wir hier im
westen sage ich jetzt mal ganz pauschal
natürlich sagen würden geschichte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wichtig sind
die beiden weltkriege die shoah der
kalte krieg fall der mauer was sind die
großen bedeutende ereignisse
währenddessen in asien 1905 das große
ereignis ist dieses ereignis ist die
schlacht bei toshiba
sie haben das hier auf ihrem cover
abgebildet ehrlich gesagt ich wusste
nichts
in dieser schlacht es geht darum dass
zum ersten mal die russische flotte
geschlagen wird von der japanischen
flotte also zum ersten mal eine
asiatische macht die eine europäische
macht schlägt warum wissen wir nichts
von diesem ereignis und warum ist es so
wichtig in asien
wir haben über all das problem dass
geschichte auf eine provinzielle
engstirnige art vermittelt im
wesentlichen lehrt man uns die
geschichte unseres jeweiligen landes
unseres nationalstaats und vielleicht im
besten fall die geschichte der regionen
oder kontinente zu denen unsere länder
gehören
das hat zur folge dass wir kaum ein
bewusstsein dafür haben was in
verschiedenen teilen der welt geschieht
wie unterschiedlich menschen rund um den
globus moderne geschichte erleben das
ist ein problem das wir überwinden
müssen und überwinden können wir es in
dem wir globale geschichte schreiben ich
verstehe mich selber nicht als
historiker aber ich glaube meine
tätigkeit ist ein versuch diese riesigen
löcher in der vorstellung der menschen
zu führen und ihnen zu zeigen dass die
geschichte der modernen welt im späten
18ten jahrhundert beginnt als unsere
welt wie wir sie heute kennen anfing
zusammenzufinden
das ist eine eng verflochtene geschichte
von er kein einziger teil separat
betrachtet werden kann
sie erwähnten zb gerade die beiden
weltkriege
man kann sagen dass die beiden
weltkriege ohne den zusammenhang mit dem
imperialismus nicht zu verstehen sind
das war miteinander verkoppelt
was wollte hitler
hitler wollte das britische empire nach
kamen die deutschen wollten ein eigenes
reich wohin gingen sie als erstes nach
afrika in deutschland gibt es jetzt
einen trend neu wird in die schulbildung
ein akzent auf kolonialgeschichte
gesetzt die meisten leute sind sich
nicht bewusst dass die deutschen in
afrika kolonien saßen und das ist dort
einen genozid gab über den man jetzt
viel spricht
es gab dort konzentrationslagern das
heißt das testlabor für das was in
europa geschah befand sich in afrika das
labor war in afrika hannah arendt
schrieb ausführlich darüber in elemente
und ursprünge totaler
einige der klügsten autorin und
historiker haben stets darauf
hingewiesen dass geschichte nicht
unterteilt werden könne in europäische
geschichte geschichte des europäischen
intel is muss oder die geschichte von
japan oder russland
wie der krieg den sie erwähnt haben wir
müssen wirklich anfangen geschichte als
etwas ganzes zu begreifen dass nicht
unterteilt werden kann was werden wir
besser verstehen wenn 1905 diese
schlacht kennen wir werden sehen dass
ein land wie japan das mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts opfer von
westlichen imperialismus wurde sich zu
modernisieren begangen zu
industrialisieren sehr hektisch ähnlich
wie deutschland um gegenüber dem westen
aufzuholen
und dass dieses verhaltensmuster dieses
muster von halsbrecherischer
modernisierung und militarisierung zu
dem geführt hat was wir als tag der
familie kennen zum angriff auf pearl
harbor so wird der zweite weltkrieg
plötzlich von einem völlig neuen winkel
her beleuchtet was wir für diesen
angriff wissen ist dass japan aus dem
nichts auftauchte
diese flugzeuge kamen aus dem nichts und
bombardierten teilhaber etwas
wahnsinniges geschah wo aber liegt die
langfristige strukturelle erklärung für
japans verhalten nicht nur international
sondern innenpolitisch was geschah in
japan im innern
welche autoren wurden von den japanern
gelesen
sie lasen deutsche denker sie lassen
fichte zu lasen kleist sie liehen sich
aus dem deutschen drehbuch wie man
industrialisiert wie man modernisiert
unter einem weitgehend undemokratischen
regime
das sind die geschichten deren wir uns
bewusst werden müssen wie ich sage es
handelt sich um eine geschichte des
austauschs eine geschichte wie leute
einander ab schauen und an japan und die
geschichte dass japan russland 1905
besiegt und wie ich im buch erkläre
sozusagen jeder wichtige asiatische
denker intellektuell
oder schriftsteller ließ sich von diesem
sieg inspirieren von gandhi zu tabori zu
atatürk zum outfit um all die bekannten
namen
es kommt ja auch sehr sehr plastisch vor
und ist unglaublich interessant zu lesen
weil eben die sagt ich konnte dieses
datum nicht unter diesem titel
umgekehrt aber wissen wir ja zb der viel
wissen es nicht aber im zuge der
recherchen bin ich darauf gestoßen und
fand das auch unglaublich interessant
dass in indien beispielsweise hitlers
mein kampf ein beliebtes buch ist dass
man jederzeit überall kaufen kann es
gilt aus management literatur als eine
art leadership bestseller und da würden
nun ja wiederum denken ja aber warum ist
dieses buch so unbestritten so
unproblematisch bei uns gab es gerade
eine riesige diskussion darüber ob man
dieses buch wieder neu herausbringen
darf also auch da gibt es sozusagen eine
ganz andere wahrnehmung der
geschichtsschreibung unter bedeutung
beispielsweise der shoah das zeigt wie
wir am anfang unserer diskussion gesagt
hatten dass geschichte immer noch
lebendig ist diese europäische
geschichte liegt in verschiedenen teilen
der welt immer noch weiter ab so dass
ein buch das von einem nazi führer
geschrieben wurde nach wie vor bereit
gelesen wird
und wichtiger noch heute regiert eine
politische bewegung die von den nazis
von hitler und mussolini inspiriert ist
indien
diese politische bewegung entstand etwa
um die gleiche zeit wie die
nationalsozialisten
ich spreche von den hindu nationalisten
die heute in indien an der macht sind
für sie war hitler einen hervorragen
oder national ist mein großvater viele
aus meiner familie sahen in hitler einen
nationalisten der sich ganz und gar
dafür einsetzte seine nation wieder groß
zu machen
eine nation die von westlichen mächten
gedemütigt worden war und was musste in
indien getan werden
das was in deutschland geschehen war
fremde wurden herausgepickt menschen die
nicht zur nationalen gemeinschaft
gehören genau das geschieht heute in
indien minderheiten werden stigmatisiert
minderheiten werden ausgemustert
so ist dieser europäische geschichte die
im neunzehnten jahrhundert beginnt und
in frühen zwanzigsten jahrhundert zu
einer fürchterlichen kombination führt
immer noch lebendig und immer noch
lassen sich menschen von adolf hitler
inspirieren
aber es zeigt uns dass wir uns die
letzten 50 60 jahre illusionen gemacht
haben
in der nachkriegszeit nach 1945 weil
europa dieses außerordentliche wachstum
verzeichnete große teile europas waren
platt gemacht durch den krieg waren sie
dem erdboden gleichgemacht
und es blieb keine andere wahl als
aufzustehen wieder aufzubauen und sie
machten einen brillanten job
die europäische union all das entstand
daraus das war ein großer erfolg
andererseits merken wir nun dass die
geschichte von dir wir glaubten wir
hätten sie hinter uns gelassen
die geschichte der konflikte des
imperialismus des kompetitiven
imperialismus die geschichte von
faschismus und nazis diese geschichte
ist nie wirklich verschwunden
sie wird wieder kommen sobald die
bedingungen die das ganze ermöglicht
hatten wieder da sind kommt auch diese
geschichte zurück
nun stehen sie aber auch für die these
zu sagen der westen ist vorbei
das ist ein auslaufmodell jetzt kommt er
wieder aufstieg asiens aber eigentlich
sagen sie doch jetzt sind die westlichen
ideen die dann wiederum für neue
zugkräfte sorgen und besorgniserregend
die mächtigen sozusagen verführen ihnen
die richtung eigentlich der der
denkweise die aus dem westen stammt also
inwiefern stimmt denn diese these
überhaupt dass der westen in untergang
begriffen ist ich glaube der westen als
kategorie ist überflüssig geworden weil
der westen heute überall ist es ist sehr
schwierig eine geografische region auf
diesem globus hier zu bestimmen von dem
man sagen kann dass es dir westen
der westen ist überall erst auf borneo
sie finden louis vitton auf borneo wo
einst kopfjäger lebten
mcdonald's auf den abgelegensten inseln
indonesiens und überall haben sie die
westliche nationalstaats ideologie ist
eine geisteshaltung eine ideologie in
diesem fall eine ideologie der
modernität alle wollen modern sein
deshalb haben sie westliche ideologien
angenommen sei es industriekapitalismus
konsum kapitalismus nationalstaat alten
ideen und ideologien die in einer
bestimmten zeit seine geschichte in
europa entstanden sind
angefangen im 17 18 jahrhundert sind nun
universell
also ist der westen universell geworden
und hat sich gleichzeitig aufgelöst weil
er universell ist die geschichte des
westens reist nun in verschiedene teile
der welt und beginnt sich zu wiederholen
natürlich mit gewissen variationen das
ist was wir heute sehen an diesem moment
aber diese these musiker verstehen die
sagen der westen schafft sich ab weil er
überall ist habe ich das richtig
verstanden das zentrum der geschichte
bewegt sich anderswo hin es verlagert
sich in weltregionen die spät zur
modernen welt gestoßen sind
wo gibt es momentan die größten
experimente
deutschland war im neunzehnten
jahrhundert im zentrum europas weil dort
modernisierung urbanisierung
industrialisierung in großem maßstab
stattfanden
jetzt ist china das zentrum der welt
weil dort all diese prozesse abgehen und
indien ist das zentrum der welt weil
dort das größte experiment in sachen
demokratie das es je gegeben hat am
laufen ist doch bedeutend dass der
aufstieg asiens eigentlich in erster
linie an ökonomischer aufstieg ist mit
der denkweise haben wir mal ganz platt
mit der kapitalistischen denkweise des
westens also kann man doch nicht sagen
der westen liegt in trümmern sondern wir
einfach sagen die produktionszentren und
vielleicht auch die wachstumsraten
verschieden sich in andere regierungen
der welt ist das ist teilweise meine
these aber ich glaube man muss das
genaue betrag
wenn experten journalisten oder leute
die in zeitungen schreiben wenn sie über
den aufstieg asiens sprechen dann in
einer sehr linearen und meiner meinung
nach stark simplifizieren den art sie
sagen das was geschah als der westen
dank gewisser vorteile die er in folge
der industrialisierung hatte dominant
wurde er industrialisierte früh
kolonisierten früh so dass sie viel
reichtum und macht anhäufen konnte dass
dieser prozess nun umgedreht werde
sodass nun asien aufsteigt mit seinen
schnelleren ökonomischen wachstumsraten
und geopolitisch zunehmenden einflüssen
das ist ein sehr vereinfachen das bild
das verkompliziert werden muss indem man
darauf hinweist dass asien gleichzeitig
mit seiner entwicklung in einem viel
größeren wirklich gewaltigen maßstab mit
den problemen konfrontiert ist die
europa am anfang seiner modernisierung
und industrialisierung zu bewältigen
hatte wenn sie diese probleme und den
massstab dieser herausforderungen mit
einbeziehen erhalten sie ein viel
komplexeres bild von dem was heute in
der welt geschieht mit dem wachsenden
populismus der zunahme autoritärer
regimes der abscheu vor demokratie
andernfalls bleiben wir auf dieser seite
journalistischen ebene stecken wo ein
steht der westen auf jetzt ist es der
osten
ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwo hin
führt lassen sie uns über diese
schwierigkeiten des populismus später
noch einmal sprechen ich möchte bei
dieser diese these noch besser verstehen
weil einerseits ist es jetzt so dass sie
sagen der westen her breitet sich
eigentlich überall aus deswegen ist es
nicht nur der westen eben sinn eines
territoriums der jetzt mächtig ist sie
sagen aber gleichzeitig auch in einem
artikel in einer spezial ausgabe von le
mans diplomatique die eigentlich den
titel ihres buches sei hier genommen
haben auf den ruinen der imperien sagen
sie der westen hat eine unglaubliche
arroganz und eine selbstgefälligkeit das
ja doch ein massiver vorwurf was genau
werfen sie denn dem westen vor
außer den historischen vorwurf sozusagen
aber das kann ja nicht alleine sein das
ist es auch nicht allein mein vorwurf
ist insbesondere in der nachkriegszeit
haben historiker journalisten die kultur
ganz allgemein in europa und amerika der
nichtwestlichen geschichte zu wenig
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt das ist mein
zentrale vorwurf
deshalb sind wir so verwirrt und
fassungslos deshalb befinden sich unsere
zeitungen unsere medien in einen krisen
zustand weil sie unfähig sind zu
erklären was heute geschieht weil sie
diese geschichte nicht als teil von der
geschichte der modernen welt angeschaut
haben die nicht geteilt werden kann
sie ist unteilbar das ist mein
hauptsächlicher vorwurf für den es keine
einfachen lösungen gibt bin ich von
intellektueller arroganz spreche meine
ich dieses denken das was in europa
geschieht in europa bleibe
sobald wir es verstanden hatten haben
wir uns weiter bewegt nie wieder wird so
etwas geschehen
das ist alles falsch den beweis dafür
haben wir heute mit der zunahme von
rechtsextremen populismus und
autoritären fremdenfeindlichen
bewegungen in ganz europa wir sehen dass
die geschichte falsch war
dieses gefühl der selbstgefälligkeit war
fehl am platz und würde sie denn sagen
wenn es die kolonialgeschichte nicht
gegeben hätte würde es heute auch keine
populistischen strömungen geben in
diesen ländern
also ist es so einfach sozusagen die
kausalitäten zuzuweisen
es gibt keine einfachen kausalitäten ich
sage die moderne welt ab dem späten
18ten jahrhundert ist ein äußerst
problematisches konstrukt
diese probleme sind periodisch sichtbar
geworden vor allem in europa nun
zunehmend auch in weiten teilen asiens
sie traten in form von klassen
konflikten in erscheinung als
massenproteste als krise der
demokratischen repräsentationen das
aufschwung autoritäre bewegungen als
zunahme von antisemitismus sowie
jeglicher art fremdenfeindlicher
bewegungen wir sehen sie noch und noch
das ganze neunzehnte jahrhundert
hindurch in deutschland in frankreich
sogar in england das eine viel
etabliertere viel erfolgreichere
liberale demokratie war diese probleme
treten nun in verschiedenen teilen der
welt auf kolonialismus und imperialismus
waren ein produkt europas im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
sie entstanden drei länder anfingen sich
zu modernisieren und die traditionelle
welt die hierarchie zu überwinden sie
begannen sich um zu sehen wo immer sie
waren und sie merkten dass andere länder
weiter waren also mussten sie aufholen
das lass nach asien und afrika gehen
neue territorien und reichtümer finden
neue rohstoffe finden sowie
industrialisierung eine grosse armee
aufbauen
soweit die kurze zusammenfassung der
modernen geschichte das alles waren
äußerst problematische unterfangen die
in weltkriegen endeten ungenutzten ich
behaupte diese geschichte setzt sich
fort sie hat nie aufgehört
1989 gab es diese selbstzufriedenheit
vom ende die geschichte
was immer lächerlicher klingt sie hat
nie wirklich aufgehört die jammers these
mit dem ende der geschichte dass
übersicht demokratien installieren
würden es hat nicht funktioniert aber
wenn sie diese diese geschichte erzählen
dann muss man natürlich auch sagen etwas
sie sagen jetzt dass sich sozusagen die
geschichte die sich fortsetzt aber was
heute natürlich wirklich angst macht ist
zum beispiel die militärische aufrüstung
in indien in china oder auch das gebaren
von china in vielen ländern afrikas soll
man das gefühl hat auch da passiert
eigentlich eine neue form
der kolonialisierung die sehr sehr
problematisch ist da würden sie sagen
dass eigentlich eine fortsetzung der
geschichte sie sehen dass in einem bogen
warum sollte dieser drang zur expansion
um eine große bevölkerung zu ernähren
genügend lebensraum für sie zu finden
plötzlich verschwinden
dieser drang der als erstes in europa
wahrgenommen wurde und zur
militarisierung von ländern zu kriegen
geführt hat diesen drang nach mehr
ressourcen mehr rohstoffen mehr platz
verspüren nun bevölkerungsreiche länder
warum haben wir je gedacht das würde
verschwinden was ich sage die moderne
welt hatte von allem anfang an viele
problematische seiten
das war der auslöser für die meisten
tragödien und katastrophen
wir waren naiv zu glauben dass wir einen
gutartigen von demokratie gesteuerten
prozess erleben wenn der westen um die
welt reist das war eine törichte
vorstellung so denken leute die nicht
wissen was eine tragödie ist
sie basiert auf der erfahrung von
menschen die in amerika leben dessen
macht zunahm während europa schrumpfte
europa wurde von zwei weltkriegen
verwüstet während beide weltkriege die
usa militärisch industriell finanziell
stärkten in jeglicher hinsicht
wer dort lebte konnte es sich leisten in
diesen optimistischen ich würde sagen
naiven manchmal dummen begriffen zu
denken
nun ich glaube leute die anderswo leben
müssen sich diesen denken nicht
anschließen heute sehen wir wie naiv es
war
bleiben wir bei dieser naivität da geht
es natürlich schon viele die der meinung
im moment mal das lassen wir uns jetzt
hier nicht vorwerfen weil der westen hat
doch dazu gelernt wir haben so was wie
die menschenrechte nachher verbrieft wir
haben ganz viele dinge aufgearbeitet wir
stehen heute ganz anders da wir stehen
heute vielleicht anders wie vor den
beiden weltkriegen zu den werten der
aufklärung wir stehen
säkularismus 1 für einen individualismus
für individuelle freiheit das ist das
was den westen ausmacht und ein
intellektueller ein historiker niall
ferguson mit dem sie sich auch heftig
öffentlich gestritten haben der ja sagt
der westen ist eigentlich die
zivilisatorische übermacht und soll es
auch bleiben
der ist natürlich der meinung um gottes
willen die müssen unbedingt dafür sorgen
dass der westen an der macht bleibt er
war hier zu gast lassen sie uns
gemeinsam ganz kurz anschauen die er
seine sicht zusammen fasst der eindeutig
beste ausgang aus meiner sicht ist wenn
die westliche zivilisation überlebt und
vorherrscht ich will nicht in einer
chinesisch oder islamisch beherrschten
welt leben denn wir würden unsere
freiheit für die freiheiten welche den
kern der westlichen kultur ausmachen
sind es wert geschätzt werden wir im
westen müssen alles tun um unsere
zivilisation zu schützen und sie vor
rückfällen zu bewahren
ökonomisch technisch kulturell und
strategisch ich finde es ist ein sehr
kompetentes plädoyer für das westliche
überlegenheit gewähren
ein standpunkt der dem westen viele
qualitäten zuspricht moralische
qualitäten im grunde spricht er dem
westen moralische überlegenheit zu ich
habe diesen standpunkt schon so lange
debattiert dass es langweilig ist noch
einmal diese ganzen argumente zu bringen
wenn wir so argumentieren wie ferguson
vergessen wir genozide wir vergessen
jahrhunderte von sklaverei eine art
struktureller gewalt die in den usa
immer noch offenkundig ist
wir vergessen die welt kriege
hungersnöte in verschiedenen teilen der
welt wir vergessen buchstäblich hunderte
kolonialer kriege die ausrottung von
ureinwohnern in australien und
neuseeland
deshalb lasst uns nicht so tun als ob
wo auch immer wir uns befinden auf
dieser welt stehen wir dazu das
menschliche gewalt betrieb zu
beherrschen betrieb zu besitzen was
andere haben der trieb zu begehren was
andere haben das sind universelle triebe
es gab momente in die geschichte als
sich gewisse weltregionen befreit haben
und manchmal nur 20 oder 30 jahren eine
wundervolle kultur und gesellschaft
kreiert ein
das geschah in die renaissance in
frankreich während der herrschaft des
sonnenkönigs
das geschah auch in europa nach 1945
weil man nicht fort konnte man musste in
europa bleiben und es wieder aufbauen
europa hatte großes glück gewisse leute
zu haben
pinelli einige christdemokraten auch
sozialdemokraten die eine vision für
europa hatten die die menschenrechte
förderten die bestimmte werte
hervorrufen
warum haben sie sie hervorgehoben weil
diese werte während einem großteil der
europäischen geschichte systematisch
verletzt worden sind deshalb wurden
diese werte hochgehalten nicht weil der
westen genetisch auf diese werte
programmiert ist sondern weil der westen
diese werte systematisch verletzt hatte
deshalb wurden sie hervorgehoben
deshalb wurde die demokratie gefördert
weil die demokratie in europa selber in
den staub getreten worden war vor 1945
das ist geschichte
das andere ist ideologie eine art glaube
religion
lasst uns eine religion aus der
westlichen zivilisation machen
ich finde wir sollten das überwinden das
ist unreif äußerst naiv wenn wir ein
ordnen wollen was auf der welt passiert
müssen wir der realität mit offenen
augen begegnen
wenn ich ihnen nun folgen und wir sagen
es gibt diese ganze diskussion seit den
terror-anschlägen ich meine es gab immer
schon terroranschlägen und muss auch
sagen die allermeisten terroranschläge
passieren ja nicht in europa das
verdrängen ja auch immer gerne aber wenn
jetzt die großen terroranschläge
europa nehmen denken die an paris denken
die anita dann haben die leute sehr
stark dieses gefühl von den müssen die
westliche gesellschaft mit diesen werten
die ferguson an land verteidigen
was sagen sie denn dazu wenn sie an ihr
müsst ihr überhaupt gar nichts
verteidigen weil diese werte gibt es bei
uns alle auch nein das meine ich
überhaupt nicht wir müssen uns vor
gewalt schützen vor terroristischer
gewalt auch vor staatsgewalt da müssen
wir ebenfalls aufpassen
wir haben erlebt dass staaten außer
kontrolle geraten sind
der mächtigste staat der welt ist außer
kontrolle geraten seit nine eleven die
usa in der art wie sie in verschiedenen
teilen der welt kriege führen
die art wie sie krieg als institution
auflösten und sich in einen endlosen
krieg gegen den terror verstrickt haben
gibt mit folter entführungen
inhaftierungen wie sie leute während
jahrzehnten ohne urteil in gefängnissen
festhalten
wir haben gesehen wie praktisch alle
westlichen werte auf die man sich nach
1945 berufen hatte verletzt wurden auch
davor müssen wir uns schützen
ich sage nicht dass man sich dem
aussetzen soll das wäre eine lächerliche
schlussfolgerung
ich sage lasst uns terrorismus verstehen
lasst uns terrorismus als teil der
problematik der modernen welt verstehen
wo gab es zuerst terrorismus übergang in
europa im späten neunzehnten jahrhundert
die erste phase des terrorismus war in
frankreich die in italien in spanien in
deutschland bismark verbot die
sozialdemokratische partei indem ihr sie
eine reihe von terrorismus attacken und
mordversuchen beschuldigte
staatsoberhäupter wurden im späten
neunzehnten jahrhundert von anarchisten
terroristen und nie listen ermordet
darunter ein amerikanischer präsident
der spanische könig viel erklärt sich
wenn sie diese geschichte auf rollen und
sehen welche art von terroristen
nihilisten im späten neunzehnten
jahrhundert sich entwickelten aus der
unzufriedenheit mit dem zustand ihrer
gesellschaft
die ungerechte gesellschaften sehr
ungleiche gesellschaften in welchen die
arbeiterschaft niedergehalten wurde
junge menschen fanden nicht genügend
jobs sie hatten keine richtige
ausbildung es gab viel frustration und
unzufriedenheit die diese terroristische
bewegungen
es gab auch eine internationale terror
bewegung angeführt von emigranten
manchmal in sehr abgelegenen teilen der
welt wie in indien oder beirut
dieses internationale netzwerk das uns
ständig verfolgt insbesondere seiten ein
eleven können sie bereits im späten
neunzehnten und zwanzigsten jahrhundert
beobachten wenn wir über terrorismus
sprechen und damit einzig den gegensatz
zwischen der westlichen zivilisation und
islamistischen fanatikern meinen ist das
eine katastrophale fehldeutung der
situation die uns in der tat noch tiefer
in dieses chaos hineingeritten hat in
dem wir uns jetzt befinden
wegen dieser vieldeutigen wegen der
endlosen kriege die in verschiedenen
muslimischen ländern geführt wurden
wegen der irak-invasion die zur
auflösung des nahen ostens geführt hat
ich glaube leute die neue ferguson
tragen große verantwortung die
geschichte wird sie dafür verantwortlich
machen dass sie die leute auf
gefährliche ideen gebracht haben wie ihr
wart einmal imperialisten ihr könnt
wieder hinein gehen ihr könnt ordnung
wiederherstellen und demokratie in
diesem teil der welt bringen
das sind die ideen die zur katastrophe
geführt haben die wir aktuell erleben
erlauben sie mir trotzdem noch einen
punkt da einzubringen
nein ich glaube es ist so wichtig dass
wir uns darüber austauschen weil ich
wirklich glaube sehr sehr viele leute
denken sowie vergessen denkt ein punkt
ist ja immer dass man sagt aber moment
mal mag schon sein dass wir einige
probleme exportiert haben mag schon sein
dass wir ganz viele dinge nicht richtig
aufgearbeitet haben und jetzt kriegen
wir die quittung dafür aber was ist zum
beispiel mit der stellung der frau in
anderen ländern wo wir den eindruck
haben dass ist doch nicht unsere
geschichte und wo die angst besteht
das 1 1 bild bezüglich des wertes der
frau nun noch zu uns importiert wird das
wir nicht haben wollen dass uns nicht
vereinbar scheint mit den
menschenrechten beispielsweise das ist
ein sehr komplexes thema noch einmal was
ich in dieser diskussion immer wieder
betonen
wenn wir anfangen das als problem
zwischen ost und west zwischen dem islam
und dem westen oder zwischen dem westen
und dem nicht westen zu betrachten
dann werden wir damit enden dass wir
moralische positionen einnehmen oder
wohlfühl positionen die uns das gefühl
geben okay wir haben das alles erreicht
wir sind großartig
schau dir diese leute an so
zurückgeblieben so naiv
sie müssen immer noch aufholen sind
immer noch am kämpfen
all die ideen von frauenrechten wenn wir
deren geschichte im westen selber
zurückverfolgen
wissen sie waren die frauen in
frankreich das stimmrecht erhalten haben
[Gelächter]
genau das meine ich wenn wir diese art
von forderungen stellen dass dieses oder
jenes segmente gesellschaft zum beispiel
lesben und schwule
wir wissen dass die schaffung von
rechtsnormen für lesben schwule ein sehr
neues phänomen ist praktisch überall in
europa im westen
die vorstellung dass ein teil der welt
hoffnungslos rückständig sei weil ihr
nicht die gleichen rechte geschaffen hat
man muss genau hinsehen wie sich die
rechte von lesben und schwulen
entwickelt haben
es ist noch nicht lange her da waren
sexuelle beziehungen zwischen männern in
großbritannien ein straftatbestand
in den usa gab es gliedstaaten wo man
dafür ins gefängnis wanderte wenn wir
über diese probleme sprechen kommen wir
besser weg von dieser speziellen zwei
teile
und anerkennen dass die rechte für
frauen die rechte von minderheiten
niemand kann heute behaupten nicht
einmal die mächtigste frau in den usa
hillary clinton wäre einverstanden wenn
jemand sagen würde die rechte der frauen
seien gesichert und geschützt richtigen
zeit tatsächlich einmal in die usa
fliegt ein bisschen schwierig das zu
behaupten
das erinnert mich sehr an meinem
gespräch mit sharon 11
die auch hier war und die die sichtbar
sie ausübten hier dargelegt hat und
erzählt hat wie im grunde genommen die
reis erzählung von flaubert der dem nil
entlang gereist ist wie er da sehr bunt
schildert welche freizügigkeit da
geherrscht hatte war ganz begeistert
über die zuständigen in den harems in
den zuständigen bruders wo man sich ja
sehr freizügig meter sexualität
vergnügen konnte und sie erzählt die
geschichte der sexualität so dass sie
eigentlich genau ihre these bestätigt es
war der imperialismus der kolonialismus
der im grunde genommen
diese
eine reaktion darauf im endeffekt dass
man gesagt hat man möchte so freizügig
wie die westler eben schlussendlich
nicht sein
aber lassen sie uns vielleicht jetzt mal
einen sprung machen weil ich denke es
ist ja auch typisch für dieses gespräch
dass wir beide versuchen die geschichte
zu verstehen oder ich versuche sie mit
ihnen zu verstehen und wir sprechen die
ganze zeit über den westen und sie
selber haben ja eigentlich zwei zuhause
sie leben einerseits in london und
andererseits im himalaya in maschera auf
2100 metern höhe sie haben da ein
teleskop wenn ich richtig informiert bin
und wenn ich sie lese habe ich manchmal
den eindruck sie versuchen die von oben
auf diese welt zu gucken
das ist ja eigentlich ein ding der
unmöglichkeit aber vielleicht können sie
mir doch sagen was sehe ich wenn ich bei
ihnen binden wie sieht die welt aus wenn
man hier im himalaya steht von meinem
balkon aus schaue ich auf tibet
ich sehe die berge und hinter den bergen
liegt tibet ich blicke also auf tibet
ich glaube aber die tatsache dass sich
in einem dorf mit 2000 einwohnern leben
das realisiere ich je länger desto mehr
hat mir eine völlig andere perspektive
gegeben auf das was in den letzten 20
jahren in indien in den anderen teilen
der welt geschehen ist in bezug auf die
globalisierung auf das globale kapital
ein problem des heutigen journalismus
und meine art von arbeit ist dass man
keinen zugang mehr hat zu den
erfahrungen breite bevölkerungsschichten
wie sie in kleinstädten und dörfern in
ganz asien leben wir alle sind davon
ausgegangen dass diese menschen in die
großen zentren ziehen so dass in ländern
wie indien und china große teile der
traditionell ländlichen bevölkerung
schliesslich in städten leben werden
dieses projekt ist gefährdet
in erster linie aus umweltgründen und
wir realisieren dass wir kaum beachtet
haben was in diesen
von geschehen ist was war das für ein
prozess der dazu führte dass menschen
aus dem dorf in die große stadt ziehen
es ist der gleiche prozess der das
europäische neunzehnte jahrhundert
prägte flaubert beschreibt es in seinen
romanen ballack schreibt darüber
und genau das geschieht heute auch in
breiten teilen indiens und chinas
wir haben aber niemanden der das aus der
nähe beobachtet insbesondere der
journalismus hat es verpasst
ein grund weshalb auch die politischen
konsequenzen dieser enormen
veränderungen nicht wahrgenommen wurden
weil ich dort lebe liegt mein fokus auf
den erfahrungen dieser menschen die in
den magazinen die sie und ich lesen
nicht vorkommen
sie haben auch eine große affinität zu
gandhi eine große affinität zu tabori
dem den großen teich dem ersten
nobelpreisträger aus dem asiatischen
raum für für literatur der großartige
dichter und er ist ja eigentlich berühmt
dafür dass ja immer für demut und
bescheidenheit plädiert hat was lernt
man den heute noch von takko oder wie
lässt sich damit sagen die mal politik
machen diese beiden figuren sind
außerordentlich wichtig im frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert gab es sowohl in
europa wie in asien nur wenige leute die
sagten
dieses modell der modernisierung der
verstädterung werde katastrophale folgen
haben und wir müssen uns bewusst sein
dass es zu tragödien und gräueltaten
führer und dass wir nicht überstürzt
nachahmen sollten was westeuropa tot
weil man sich damit jegliche formen von
konflikten und spaltungen einhandelt
kann die und tore waren zwei menschen
die das sehr deutlich erkannt haben
die gesehen haben dass die moderne
industriegesellschaft jene zivilisation
für die sich neue folge sind stark macht
zutiefst fehlerhaftes konstrukt war dass
kriege und konflikte beinhaltet
deshalb bieten sie ihren mitbürgern und
allen die auf sie hören wollten sie
wissen tage reiste überall hin
auch in die schweiz nach deutschland
amerika ich habe sogar ein sehr schönes
gespräch gefunden zwischen ihm und
einstein war 1930 hat ein steinigen nach
berlin eingeladen
die beiden haben sich sehr gut
verstanden und das gespräch kann man
lesen auszüge daraus ist sehr
interessant
ja ich kenne es ist ein wunderbares
gespräch einstein war sehr zugänglich
für beide kam die und al gore
es gab europäer die sehr aufgeschlossen
waren speziell gegenüber ta gore seine
botschaft wurde damals aber nicht gehört
das gleiche sagte er auch zu japan was
ihr tut ist außerordentlich gefährlich
es würde zu einer größeren katastrophe
führen
er war prophetisch als die japaner in
den krieg zogen als sie in china
eindrangen
lange bevor sie die vereinigten staaten
angriffen drangen sie in china ein
wurden seine schlimmsten befürchtungen
bestätigt er hat das muster über das wir
vorher gesprochen haben erkannt wie
japan in seiner gier nach macht und
reichtum verrückt wurde
davor hat er die ganze zeit gewartet er
hat den leuten gesagt ob wir nun den
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten traf
oder vor einem publikum in argentinien
sprach dass wir hier wirklich vorsichtig
sein müssen andernfalls würden unsere
gesellschaften ähnlich wie die
europäischen werden und alle pathologien
und probleme unter welchen diese gerade
leiden importieren wenn sie die heutige
welt betrachten bin ich überzeugt sie
hätten schwierigkeiten jemanden zu
finden der prophetischer und vor
aussehender war als ob ihm dran agora
ich frage nun trotzdem wieder mit meinem
unglaublich westlich verbrämten
hintergrund weil ich keinen anderen habe
mir ist in diesem zusammenhang martha
nussbaum eingefallen die große
politische philosophin aus den usa die
hat ein buch geschrieben vor ein paar
jahren politischer emotionen sie
plädiert darin dafür zu sagen wir können
politik nicht nur mit argumenten
betreiben wir brauchen gefühle und sie
setzt hier darin zum beispiel reden von
martin luther king und zeigt auf oder
roosevelt dass die großen politischen
veränderungen mit emotionen eigentlich
ihren anfang genommen haben und ein ganz
ganz großes kapitel ist agora gewidmet
und sie sagt im grunde genommen fehlt
uns heute so etwas wie eine politik des
mitgefühls und jetzt kommt meine frage
gegeben vielleicht waren sie sich nicht
links ist das nicht so ein romantisches
bild wir könnten einander eben mit demut
und bescheidenheit mit mitgefühl
begegnen und damit die welt verändern
ich kann das nicht richtig einordnen
ich finde im party und mitgefühl haben
definitiv nicht den stellenwert der
ihnen in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft zukommen sollte wenn wir
über demokratie sprechen sprechen wir
über leute die basierend auf argumenten
eine wahl treffen
aufgrund von eigeninteressen die größten
theoretiker der modernen welt wie wir
sie heute bewohnen
ob adam smiths oder mode ist beliebig
viele französische englische oder
schottische denker die einem in den sinn
kommen
natürlich sprachen sie über anteilnahme
die bedeutung von mitgefühl
aber die priorität wurde auf die idee
der rationalität gelegt auf das
eigeninteresse in gewissem sinn hat das
letztlich die welt angetrieben
wir benennen unser eigenen interesse das
irgendwie mit dem eigeninteresse der
anderen zusammentrifft was zu
allgemeinem wohlstand führt das ist kurz
zusammengefasst
da passt dann haben wir noch so etwas
wie rechte die dafür sorgen dass die
freiheit des einzelnen nur so weit geht
die die rechte des anderen wieder
beginnen also rechte rationalität
eigenen kresse argumente der rechtsstaat
wurde eingeführt um die macht bis zu
einem gewissen grad zu regulieren und
zur kontrolle von individuellem
verhalten damit das individuum nicht die
rechte der anderen beeinträchtigt leute
wie tagoe argumentierten dies sei eine
sehr beschränkte art über menschliche
beziehungen zu denken die wirkungsvolle
menschliche emotionen außer acht lässt
wie anteilnahme und mitgefühl gefühle
für andere menschen das bewusstsein dass
keiner von uns ohne andere menschen
existieren kann da noch was dass wir
alle voneinander abhängig sind
weil er das erkannt hat betonte er das
wichtigste für das zusammenleben von
menschen sei ob in einer nation oder in
einer kleinen kirchengemeinschaft das
wichtigste sein vertrauen und mitgefühl
important wir haben diese werte aus den
augen verloren wenn nun maße nußbaum
über die rolle von gefühlen schreibt
ich glaube ich habe eines ihrer bücher
besprochen indem sie diesen punkt
erwähnte und das demokratie auf der
anerkennung der würde des anderen
basiere und dass diese anerkennung die
möglichkeit von anteilnahme und
mitgefühl beinhalte wir sind zu rational
geworden in der art wie wir uns selber
in beziehung zu anderen wahrnehmen und
wie wir unsere gesellschaften wahrnehmen
und politische theorie hat sehr wenig
platz für gefühle
ich verstehe was sie meinen aber machen
wir den bogen zurück zum anfang des
gesprächs sie haben sehr früh erwähnt
dass ein großes problem nationalismen
und auch der populismus ist in vielen
vielen
ich habe die hindunationalisten erwähnt
aber das ja nicht das einzige land wir
sehen auf der ganzen welt populistische
strömungen explodieren und eigentlich
kann man sagen wir leben in einem
wirklich in einer wirklich schwierigen
zeit die mir persönlich auch große
sorgen macht und ich weiß dass ihr
nächstes buch sich mit dem phänomen des
hauses beschäftigen wird der hass der
eigentlich um spannende moment die welt
beschäftigt und da frage ich mich muss
man dem haus nicht so etwas sie einfach
rechte und argumente entgegen setzen
nützt es etwas zu sagen ja lasst uns
wieder mehr mitgefühl empfinden
ich weiß nicht recht ob wir damit den
hass besiegen können
um noch einmal auf unser bisheriges
gespräch zurück zu kommen
dieses problem wurde von anfang an
erkannt von rousseau und ich glaube im
neunzehnten jahrhundert dann auch von
tocqueville er ging in den 1800 30er
jahren nach amerika und sah wie diese
neue gesellschaft entstand eine
gesellschaft basierend auf
individualismus eigeninteresse und auch
auf wettbewerb weil die alten
hierarchien abgeschafft waren standen
nun alle in konkurrenz zueinander
er sah die politischen gefahren dieser
entwicklung sehr deutlich die leute
würden anfangen sich über ihre
konkurrenten zu ärgern und diese wut
diese unruhe
diese frustration könnte schließlich
dazu führen dass sie sich nach einem
starken mann sehnen nach jemandem der
ihn steht und befehle erteilt und im bus
oder die entwicklung vom individualismus
zum despotismus wie wir sie heute
erleben war schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert angelegt
über diese wut sprechen dann stelle ich
mir auch die frage ist eigentlich die
wut der menschen die sagen wir mal
irgendwo in deutschland flüchtlingsheime
anzünden und die wut der menschen die
dem es bei treten ist dass dieselbe
sie hat ähnliche gründe
es ist nicht die gleiche wut die eine
ist offensichtlich destruktiver und
mörderischer als die andere aber ich
glaube der ursprung liegt darin dass
sich menschen zutiefst machtlos fühlen
machtlos gegenüber unbekannten kräften
die nicht identifiziert werden können
gegen die es keine bekannten politischen
abhilfen gibt im zeitalter der
globalisierung fühlen sich die menschen
besonders machtlos weil der
nationalstaat als garant von rechten und
von staatsbürgerschaft geschwächt worden
ist deshalb fühlen sie sich diesen
gewaltigen unpersönlichen kräften
stärker ausgesetzt
vorher sprachen wir über terrorismus und
weshalb er im späten neunzehnten
jahrhundert aufkam
wegen der entstehung von globalen
kapitalismus neuen ungleichheiten auch
internationale migration
einige dieser vorfälle wiederholen sich
heute
sie haben viel migration sie haben viele
flüchtlingsbewegungen ausländern die
zerfallen
gleichzeitig hat der nationalstaat
schwierigkeiten die es zu bewältigen
weil er seine souveränität aufgegeben
hat er kann nicht mehr so eingreifen wie
früher in gewissem sinn zeigt sich
dieses problem noch einmal an sie denken
mit ihrem teleskop in cobra was würden
sie denken wenn sie von oben auf die
welt blicken könnten was braucht diese
welt eine große frage aber was braucht
unsere welt damit diese globalisierung
irgendwie zu einem langen die rheiner
geschichte wird die die menschen
irgendwie wirklich auch im richtigen
sinne zusammenbringt es braucht
definitiv ein gefühl eine fähigkeit eine
zuversicht dass wir etwas verändern
können
dieser zustand völliger hilflosigkeit
völliger machtlosigkeit und dieses
gefühl dass bei andere menschen irgendwo
über dein schicksal bestimmen die du
manchmal nicht einmal identifizieren
kann
das ist ein gefühl dass menschen auf
jegliche art extremistischer lösungen
bringt es treibt sie in die arme von
demagogen zu mörder bewegungen wie dem
islamischen staat
es führt dazu dass menschen das gesetz
in die eigenen hände nehmen
flüchtlingszentren bombardieren und so
weiter die vorstellung dass ich als
individuum gemeinsam mit anderen
individuen einen gewissen grad von
souveränität kontrolle und macht über
mein leben habe
ohne dieses gefühl wird das erwähnte
phänomen immer schlimmer wie schaffen
wir dieses gefühl das ist im moment die
größte frage
die größte herausforderung vor der wir
stehen mit dieser herausforderung können
wir nur fertig werden
wenn wir die situation richtig
einschätzen wenn wir in dieser haltung
west gegen ost islam gegen den westen
islam in europa stecken bleiben können
wir nichts erreichen
am anfang unserer these thermische ramiz
den zusammenhang immer wieder
eingefallen das zitat von georg gadamer
immer gesagt hat die geschichte gehört
nicht uns sondern wir gehören der
geschichte ich glaube das ist die essenz
dessen was sie erzählen
wir sind vielleicht auch unseres
gesprächs ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
an mich schon dass sie hier waren
dankeschön für nächste woche denken die
in den sternstunden weiter darüber nach
wie ein friedvolles zusammenleben in
einer multikulturellen welt gelingen
kann
unser gast moderator wolfram eilenberger
trifft den historiker timothy garton ash
und spricht mit ihm über rede freiheit
und toleranz jetzt gleich sehen sie hier
ein porträt über den britischen
kunstkritiker john byrne sein
lebensthema
ist die kunst der genauen betrachtung
und der film über ihn ist eine herzliche
einladung unvoreingenommen sehen zu
lernen
ich danke ihnen fürs zuschauen und ich
wünsche ihnen einen guten sonntag
[Musik]